hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast intuitive and easy
programming of liquid handling tasks
with ep motion presented by dr. Carsten
Wolman an international product manager
at Eppendorf and dr. Tim Hamid an
application specialist at liquid
handling in Eppendorf I'm Suzy Valdez of
lab route and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab routes and sponsored by
eppendorf ethanoic is a leading life
science company that develops and sells
instruments consumables and services for
liquid sampling and cell handling in
laboratories worldwide before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that
green Q&A button located at the lower
left of your presentation window and
type your questions into the box that
appear on that screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem I'd now like to introduce our
two presenters for today's webinar
first dr. Carsten Bowman dr. Bowman has
a scientific background in biochemistry
molecular and cell biology he has more
than 18 years of experience in life
sciences marketing and is working as an
international project manager in
automated liquid handling at Eppendorf
our second presenter dr. Tim Shama
dr. Shah mots works and as an
application specialist for automated
liquid handling at Eppendorf
headquarters in Hamburg Germany
he studied molecular life science in
Germany and in Singapore focusing on the
influence of anti-inflammatory
antibodies on allergies and autoimmune
diseases during his master
thisis Tim Shamas holds a PhD in
chemistry working in the VIP field of
biology
he joined Eppendorf in 2016 having a
broad background in different workflows
ranging from molecular biology cell an
infection biology to the mule ji and
biochemistry
welcome gentlemen I'll turn it over to
you thank you Susie for the kind
introduction and welcome everybody for
today's webinar so what I would do is in
the webinar we will given short
introduction to automated liquid
handling and as this instrumentation is
used in many application and workflow
will shortly explain in what
applications workflows the automated
liquid handling systems are used in and
then we will explain how easy it is to
break it down the easy different
applications workflow to certain
building blocks and then explain how
easy it is to program and handle this
building blocks to build up the
application and transfer them to
automatic liquid handling systems then
we will close in the second part of the
talk then with explaining all the
various advantages of the automated
liquid handling systems and then close
from the presentation with some short
overview about our EP motion portfolio
so you might know Eppendorf for decades
already for handheld liquid handling
devices and other lab equipment but for
more than 15 years we offer already also
automatic liquid handling systems with
our if you motion product line and what
these automatic liquid handling systems
are doing they are also called piping
workstations or liquids handlers or
patterning robots and it's very simple
what they do first of all they transfer
or liquids at different volume levels
from destination vessels to sauce no the
other way around from source vessels to
destination vessels and this can be from
juice to plates from plate to plate or
from reservoirs to tubes or plates and
so on so it's very simple on how it
sounds
however in addition the liquid handling
systems can also perform a lot of other
capabilities so they can mix by
pipetting or have mixing capability on
deck so that you can do a motor-driven
mixing of plates or other lap wear and
of course you can also have a
temperature incubation for cooling and
heating of reagents and samples doing
incubations and so on for a lot of
applications you need to transport the
Liguilla plates from one position to
temperature incubation position and so
on so we can transport like we're on the
working deck and form some applications
so we can also do separation by magnetic
or vacuum support on deck of the
automatic liquid handling systems which
is used for nucleic acid purification or
other solid phase extraction you will
see the instruments the liquid handlers
are quite capable and do more than just
positing so we see nice flexibility of
the automated liquid handling systems
they can be used for a really wide a
broad application area so on the next
slide here I want to just briefly talk
about what are our customers currently
doing with our IP motion system so they
they use the promotion system
for applications like the next
generation sequencing libel preparation
but a lot of customers are also doing
PCR setup or nucleic acid extraction for
various kits that can be provided from
various vendors and we also have a lot
of customers doing surveys essays there
is more in a plate to plate format or
compound screening eliezer essays other
biochemical essays snip assay so there
are really a lot of different
applications that can be handled on
these automation systems so there are a
lot of application notes available on
our website but you can also screen for
emotion in scientific publications to
find really how often these
instrumentation is used and how it is
used
so before I transfer over to Tim I would
just say that or introduce that he will
show you now how easy and intuitive it
is to program and transfer these
applications to an automated liquid
handling system so Tim please ah thank
you very much Karsten so I will take
over from here and I'm sorry um so most
of the workflows can be broken down into
several parts so they usually start with
a sample which then goes through
preparation or purification processes
which leads to an analysis and which
will finally give you a result and each
of those different parts again consists
of building blocks which I will come to
in a second and those building blocks
again consists of several functional
steps so if we for example look at a
dilution building block a dilution is a
combination of several liquids
we define concentration and looking at
automated liquid handling we will mainly
look at the building blocks of the
preparation part but obviously you can
also use an automated liquid liquid
handler for downstream processes after
you've got your results and continue
with subsequent experiments so let me
move on to the building blocks of the
workflows so we divided a workflow into
seven major building blocks which are
reformatting dilution carry or heat
picking normalization mixing incubation
with or without temperature and
transports for example to a vacuum
device or to a magnet
I will now walk you through all of those
building blocks let's start with
reformatting what do we mean if we talk
about reformatting so reformatting
simply describes the transport of a
liquid from one vessel to another so
those vessels can either be tubes or
plates they can come in different
formats so one well to 384 words and
reformatting is by far one of the most
common and also one of the most
important building blocks in all of the
complex applications you handle everyday
so this might sound a little bit
abstract so I I've tried to fill this
with more lives looking at everyday
example from the lab so let's say you
want to transfer samples from cubes to a
plate in the manual workflow you would
do this with a manual pipette take out
the sample from the tubes put it in your
place or in a more carton eyes depiction
you take out liquids from one vessel and
transfer it to another vessel either in
one or in several wells and how is this
transferred into our automation software
there is a very simple command which is
called sample transfer and this table
transfer allows you to transfer samples
of different nature for example if you
do some the replication plate
multiplication or also some of the
normalization so how do we do this in
the EP blue software let's take a look
at the software this is how the software
looks like and at the first step you
start with populating your work table
which is basically what you would do if
you would populate your lab bench with
all of the desired lab where you want to
use for your experiment so from the
drop-down menu in the left you choose
your desired lab work which can be for
example plates or also tips or any other
type of lab where you then choose the
the specific types of tips for example
that you want to use for your experiment
so in this case 50 micro liter tips with
the filter and you simply drag and drop
it to the work table you then end up
with your tips being placed on the work
table you then step-by-step populates
your work table with all of the desired
level that you need if you want to
change some settings so you can for
example change the name of the lab wear
on the work table once you are finished
with putting and populating left wear on
the work table and changing the names
you can then simply switch to adding
commands by clicking on the switch to
procedure button you will then come to
another window which looks like this and
there you can drag-and-drop commands to
your procedure list simply by moving
them from the menu to the left into your
procedure list
in this example we are using a sample
transfer you then choose the tool you
want to use for this for this process
the transfer type so either pipetting or
multi dispense and the volume you want
to move you choose your source and your
destination vessel and you then click on
patterns and simply choose the pattern
how you want the private pipetting
process to proceed so in an enlarged
view you can see here that we transfer
the sample from tube number one - well a
one of our plate and we transfer the
sample from tube number seven - well T
one of our plates so this is a very easy
one - one sample transfer but you can
also do something like this so in this
case we do a triplicate
so we transfer the sample from tube one
- well a one two a three of our pcr
plate and so on so if you look at this
you might think that this will need
quite a lot of clicking in fact this is
not true
because our software involves a smart
and patented pattern recognition
algorithm and it works like this at the
first step you click on your source tube
and then you click on your three
destination valves you then click on
your second source tube and the software
will automatically suggest the well B 1
to B 3 as your destination right so it
will recognize that you want to do
triplicates to fill up your plate you
can simply click on command
as the software has recognized the
pattern you are using it will fill up
the full plate with only one click all
right let me move on to a second example
again something which you do in the lab
all the time so how about this pending
reagents from let's say a chronicle tube
to a plate a process which you would do
a multi dispense mode for example with
an electronic pipette so in a more
simplified view this means taking out
liquid from one vessel and putting it
into several welds or several other
vessels for this process we have a
command called reagent transfer with
which allows the distribution of
reagents from one well or one column to
many destinations again to use this
command after populating the work table
you simply drag and drop the command
from the menu on the left to the
procedure list you then choose a tool
that you want to use the transfer type
in this case we're using the multi
dispense mode the tips and the volume
you want to transfer you would select
your source and your destination vessel
and you choose your pipetting pattern in
this case our source vessel is our
reagent rack this reagent rack is a
modular piece of lab work which allows
the use of vessels of different shape
and size in in in one position so here
we have for example 15 milliliter
chronicles 50 milliliter chronicles and
1.5 milliliter reaction tubes on one a
Dec position so and for the reagent
transfer here we transfer liquid from
the position 1 a of our reagent
to our PC I'll play to all of the worlds
of our PCR plate so let me very quickly
explain you the different between
pipetting and multi dispensed mode so if
we talk about pipetting we're referring
to a process where you aspirate a given
amount of liquid and then you dispense
this total amount of liquid into one
destination this mode allows to use a
blowout which makes it possible to
handle also difficult liquids for
example liquid liquids which contain a
high level of great glycerol it's a very
accurate liquid transfer mode the multi
dispense mode works a little different
you take up a large amount of liquid and
this liquid is then subsequently
dispensed into several destination wells
this works faster than the pipetting
mode and allows multiple deliveries with
only one tip which saves consumables and
as you can see here in this presentation
in our pipetting and also multi dispense
mode there is always a little air gap at
the tip of the tip in this case and this
makes a contamination free movement of
liquids possible and it's a safety
measure to protect your precious
reagents and your important samples one
last reformatting example how about the
removal of liquids from a plate to a
waste Wessel this is something which you
could imagine for example if you wash
eliezer plates and a process that you
would manually do and most of the cases
with a channel pipette to speed up the
process so if we go to the to a more
simplified view this means that we take
out liquid from several wells and
transfer it into one destination well so
the command we use is called pool to one
destination and it allows the
consolidation of samples to one well or
one column in the software again after
populating the worktable you simply drag
and drop the command to to the procedure
list you select your a tool you want to
use in this case we are using a
multi-channel tool the volume you want
to aspirate and your source and
destination you then choose your desired
type adding pattern and as you can see
here we are aspirating liquid from the
whole plate and transferring it into a
waste reservoir so of course you can not
only use those different commands
isolated but you can simply combine
commands as you would do it with manual
steps so as for example you first want
to distribute your you your reagent you
do this with a reagent transfer and you
then add your samples to your reagent
and did you do with the sample transfer
in our if you blue software and this is
realized by simply dragging and dropping
those commands in our procedure list you
can add as many commands and steps as
you want and those commands will then be
performed as input in the list
subsequently by the device all right let
us move to the next filling block which
is a dilution series something which you
do very often in the lab so this means
that you work with stock samples or any
stock solution and you dilute them
mostly in a well format with
let's say a multi-channel pipette to
have several delusions of your stock
solution for this we have our dilute
command which allows serial diluting of
one or eight samples with a common
sector something very useful for
standard curve preparation or also the
preparation of working solution in the
software after populating your work
table selecting the dilute command and
the desired volume here you simply
choose your your stock solution in this
case we're using our reagent rec in a
different setup with the eight strip
here in the first position we have done
one point five milliliter 50 milliliter
chronicles and three reservoirs and we
then transfer this to our destination
plate where we do a serial dilution over
the full plate meaning over all of the
twelve columns off the plate let's now
move on to the let's say a little bit
more exotic building blocks so first we
take a look at so-called cherry or hit
picking this means picking several
samples from one plate which might be in
a rather chaotic order and concerned
consolidating them on one hit plate this
is a very tedious and error-prone work
if you do this manually so if we want to
take a look how this is realized by the
EP blue software we can simply do this
by using our pattern so here we have to
select our sauce well so let's say a six
and we move the sample from this world
through our destination world which is a
1 and we do this
for all of the other examples we want to
pick the problem with this process is
that you still have to look in your list
and figure out which which sample goes
into which well and which well you have
to pick so still there is a little
option for our making mistakes here so
there is a more convenient way to do it
picking and one thing I want to
highlight here is what you have noticed
is that our software is also able to
work with a regular pattern so as you
see that the pattern from the source
plate is chaotic so the system doesn't
want to find a pattern here if you take
this box okay but let's go back to the
more convenient way to do hit picking in
order to do this we use so-called CSV
files which are nothing has been an
excellent a data list or a separate
value file so a file you prepare
beforehand where you sum up all of your
pipetting steps so how does such a list
look it's a very simple list so the
first two columns describe your source
and the third and the fourth column they
describe your destination you then
choose the volume you want to transfer
and the tool you want to use in this
case the single-channel tool for 50
micro litre and you can always give a
name for your samples so once you've
prepared this table you can go to your
if you do software you populate your
work table here we are seeing our table
of different if emotion type if emotion
50 73 which has slightly more deck
positions as you have seen before
and what you do is you you program a
sample transfer step and you choose the
volume to be zero microliter you then
choose your source and your destination
in this case we are pipetting from a380
well plate 2 and 96 website you then
simply click on the CSV import button
you choose your hit picking list to your
desired CSV file you choose your CSV
import options in this case we go for
the transfer type pipette which allows
to transfer each sample with the
individual pipetting step to avoid
contamination and once you've done this
you can see here in your procedure list
that your CSV file is converted into a
number of sample transfer steps so this
allows you to very conveniently do hit
picking all right along the same lines
we will look at the next building block
which is normalization normalization
describe the process where you dilute
samples with different concentration to
1 define concentration for all in a
lattice sample this is one task in the
lab which I personally hate it because
it involves tons of pipetting steps and
it's extremely error-prone so I would
highly recommend you to to use if you
have the option automated liquid handing
for this task and for the EP blue
software again use CSV files which is a
very fast and convenient way to do your
everyday normalization tasks in the lab
in this case our table looks just a tiny
bit different
again we have our source and our
destination we have the volume and we
have the tool we want to use for the
step the the difference is that in the
in these flyers we can give a source for
both the samples and the diluent as you
can see for the sample here and for the
diluent here so how you import this into
our EP blue software so again first you
populate your work table here we're
seeing another EP blue ep motion version
I'm sorry which is the 5075 and has the
largest debt capacity so you you program
a step again with zero micro litre
pipetting and then you choose your
source for both the diluent and the
samples in this case the diluent comes
from a reservoir and the samples come
out of the deep website you also choose
your destination and we will consolidate
our samples on a pcr plate here you then
simply click on the CSV import button
choose your arm CSV file you want to
import and then choose your CSV import
up options in this case we are going for
the multi dispense mode which allows to
use the multi dispense mode for
replicates of equal volume this saves
both time and consumables once you've
done this you can see that the CSV file
is again translated into a number of
sample transfer commands which now use
the multi dispense mode so net so all of
those commands I have presented you in
the last minutes are dealing with the
trans
of liquids but you know that lab where a
lab work is more than just transferring
liquids so we will now look at the
so-called auxilary commands which
involves mixing intubation and transport
steps so the commands we are talking
about here is for example the weight
command which has been used for
incubation step and allows to wait
between two steps you've given in your
procedure list another command is the
pipette mixing where you can mix a
liquid with a pipette just as you would
do for example with the master mix
always a bead solution you can here
simply choose the number of mixing
cycles the mixing speed and the volume
you want to mix another command very
important command is the transport
command and this allows the automated
relocation or stacking of lab where with
a gripper which you can see here so in
the software you simply choose the lab
where you want to move and to which
position it should be moved we have a
Pierce command the Pierce command allows
to work with sealed place either with
film or foil these film or foil is then
pierced with a single channel tool to
allow the aspiration of the liquids
underneath if you have a magnetic
separation device you can turn on and
off the magnet using the magnetic
separation command and you can do this
for your choice of time if your system
comes with thermal modules you can set
the temperature for those modules to
allow teaching or cooling on deck if
your device has a thermal mixer which is
a combination of shaker and thermal
plate you can choose you
our mixing speed your mixing time and
the temperature
last but not least if you have a device
with a vacuum chamber you can you can
choose the pressure of your vacuum and
the duration of the vacuum this is very
useful if you deal with so the plates
for example for nucleic acid binding
washing and dilution
so now after we've been through all of
those building blocks it's very
important to mention that all of these
blocks can be combined in any order and
by any number - and this allows to
display even the most complex workflows
so if we look for example at a PCR
reaction mix you have your template DNA
which comes from either hit picking it
might be normalized
maybe it's diluted and definitely it
will be some sort of reformatting
process you then have your master mix
which might also be diluted and
reformatted and you have your primers
which can be diluted again and they will
be reformatted and if you bring all of
those components together you have your
PCR application and on the EP motion you
can simply realize this by aligning
different commands let's take a look at
another complex workflow which is the
big cleanup which can for example be
part of the NGS library preparation and
as you can see here in this slide so you
can break down complex workflow into
several single steps so so you start
with the mixing of the beads into the
sample you do this with the reagent
transfer and pipette mixing you then
incubate this just use the wait command
you move on and do the magnetic
separation you transport your plate to
the magnet there
you then use the pool to one destination
command to remove the supernatant the
next three commands first the adding of
the wash buffer with a reagent transfer
then you move it to the magnet and you
incubate and two and separate and then
you remove the supernatant so this
washing process can be repeated several
times and after you've done with the
washing you usually have a drying step
you do this by waiting and incorporating
a thermal module with a temperature step
you then transport your plate back to
the magnet use the reagent transfer and
a mixing command to resuspend your beats
an illusion buffer and you then do the
final incubation and separation by
moving your sample and applying a
temperature in the end you will transfer
your supernatant with your nucleic acids
to a fresh plate so and if we then take
also the beat cleanup and the PCR as a
building blocks consisting of smaller
building blocks you can think about the
most complex workflows so here for
example you have a workflow which
incorporates a big cleanup then there
might be several steps in between there
then there can be a PCR may be some
other steps and in the end you will have
another big cleanup but as I could show
you in the previous slides you can all
break down those steps into simple
commands which you can align in the
software in your procedure list so I
hope in the last slides I could convince
you that programming in ep blue is fast
and easy by just dragging and dropping
commands so let me just quickly wrap up
the EP blue software benefits so you
have a standalone editor which allows
programming and your desktop PC so you
don't have to sit
to the machine all the time our
graphical user interface is very
intuitive and comes with drag-and-drop
programming for both library and
commands we are using a lot of smart
commands which can be understand very
quickly we have a comprehensive level
repository with tons of labra fires from
different vendors which can be used on
the machine a very important feature is
also the 3d method simulation which you
can see down here so this allows the in
silico run of your method to avoid the
loss of precious reagents or consumables
and we offer a lot of pre optimized
methods for example for nucleic acid
purification next-generation sequencing
library preparation and allows a lot of
other application and but decides the
easy programming automation also offers
you a lot of other benefits and I guess
that Carsten will introduce them to you
now yeah okay thank you Tim I hope
everyone could really understand that
it's now really fast and easy to program
various routine applications on
automatic little liquid handling systems
like our it emotions and of course there
are many good advantages of the
automatic liquid handling so they are
listed here that the first one would be
the relativity of the system as we have
seen from from Tim's presentation with
all the different commands you can build
up the building blocks and with that you
can really implement a lot of
applications on one of the same system
so you can do look like as a
purification PCR setup you can do cherry
picking which is also very error-prone
tasks you can do Eliza preparation
Senate culture work even
and one of the most complex and but also
very tedious and labor-intensive
application nowadays is the
next-generation sequence e-library
preparation which is definitely
something which is very useful to do
this in an automated way so another
advantage is the throughput capabilities
of the automatic systems you think you
can do the reformatting just from one
tube of youtubes but certainly it were
happy to increase the throughput and the
efficiency in your lab because you
easily can now start to work with plates
or with several plates in in one batch
of your application runs so definitely
the throughput is increased with
automated liquid handling however you
not always have to applied for really
high throughput applications it's it's
worth doing it a few as we have seen it
in some examples from Tim doing the
normalization it's worth doing it in an
automated way already with a few samples
let's say eight or about twenty four
samples it's already very reasonable to
do this in an automatic way already so
you can be a very experienced manual
liquid handling device user however
usually the accuracy and the precision
of an automated system is much better if
you use an automated system on drum here
below we have collected some experiments
so they are documented in an application
note where the the accuracy and
precision of the pcr setup on why manual
or by automated means were compared and
definitely the accuracy and precision of
the automated method
this much superior so this is also an
advantage of the automatic liquid
handling like for instance the next one
which is the halfway or the reduction of
human errors during all the parting
steps so in in a recent study we have
seen that that there are many reasons
why you can have failures during your
positing however in about 70% of the
cases here and the data from the recent
survey is showing that it is due to
parking by the user which is the main
portion of the errors in in this case so
this is definitely reduced by switching
to automation another advantage is all
the sample tracking and documentation
that you need to do in the laboratory
you can imagine that or you have to
document everything in your lap' journal
but the automated system is doing this
in a very comprehensive and detailed log
file which is provided for each run with
the system so for instance there's a
tracking for the barcodes or the sample
name or the operator obviously need to
log in in the system and with that it is
documented of course the time and also
the procedure or method which is used
the position of the sample in a plate
from where - what destination do you do
the pocketing and of course the device
status is also documented and all the
volumes of the pocketing action are also
documented in one very detailed and
combined log file so this is
very convenient for for you as a user
and definitely an advantage on for
automated liquid handling systems the
promotion has really a nice combination
of multi-level contamination prevention
so this is done first of all by an a
complete enclosure of the system and
also we see on top clean cap where an
HEPA filter and and UV light is included
you get further protection of your
samples inside of the if emotions but
there are other contamination prevention
measures it is the contact free or free
jet pipetting nodes which is used with
AP motion or using sterilizer tips
autoclavable paddling tools that is
really standard for our parking system
that you really can take out the tools
and send it for not Senate can send it
for calibration but you can do the other
collaboration Auto collaboration by
yourself then we have all our tip
qualities we have parasitic qualities
but the PCR clean is one of the highest
qualities for our tips we have an
command which is the rinse feature so
this can be used to rinse and clean a
pocketing tip after the action before
you put it to waste which can also help
to prevent contamination and there are
other optimizations within the EP blue
software so with all these multi-level
contamination Prevention's you are
protecting your samples and your
reagents which is very important however
it's also important that you protect
yourself
during all this routine essays and also
protects any operator from all the bio
hazardous substance that you might work
with for instance if you work with blood
or other body liquids and of course we
are working with viruses or other
pathogens in your laboratory work so
protecting personal protection is also a
very good advantage for using automation
in your lab so and last but not least
there is of course
combined with any automation in the lab
you increase this standardization
because you're working with fixed
methods which you use again and again
and which gives you a standardization to
your work and with that you also get an
increase of the reproducibility of your
results which is very good because if
you imagine you work with different
operators each operator will have its
own reproducibility but finally the
results will different from each other
and really a good reproducibility means
that from several usages you are getting
really close in the result and this is
achieved with using automation
increasing the reproducibility of your
results so if we have your time with
ease of use by switching to automated
liquid handling so it increases the
productivity of your work you will have
less errors or failures in the
experiments you need less repetitions of
your experiments once they are failed
and with that you get an better
efficiency and I think it's very clear
that everyone has a lot of roots
liquid handling tasks everyday in his
lab like the reformatting that Tim
talked about deductions he picking or
even the very tedious and
labor-intensive normalization steps so
this is done in pretty much every
laboratory day in day out and these are
really nice and simple applications that
are easy to transfer to automatically
liquid handing but it can also be more
complex applications like the NGS
library preparation that are really very
reasonable to ultimate well because for
infinitives
and manual work will take about two days
of hot pocketing and very concentrated
work very tedious and it's very
repetitious and with automation you can
really reduce this to only 1.5 hours of
hands-on time with the help of the EP
motion and this really frees you up to
spend more time on other sophisticated
scientific work in in your lab ok so
with that I would like to come to a
short introduction to our product
portfolio so we have three different
types of emotional systems so from the
largest one which has four deck
positions but you can have virtual deck
positions which are used in the
programming and this can be indefinite
so you can program methods and in
between here the software will ask you
to replace like we're in the system
before the run continues so with that
you really can increase the capacity and
to complexity of the applications even
with a small system but we also have
the next level of implementation which
has six positions and also the
capability of using a gripper device and
then we have a set of larger systems
which have up to 15
declan's and then also waist position is
available on all the devices and up to
four positions for exchanging the
positing tools and of course the larger
systems can also handle a gripper so
with the different capabilities it is
also different usage of applications
usually the small system to EB motion
5070 is used for PCR setup and general
liquid handling tasks while the v6
position system VP motion fifty seventy
three it's used for a bit more complex
methods like new glazes nucleic acid
preparations be based purifications or
also a lot for PCR setup and then the
larger system that is really useful for
the more complex and for applications
with a little bit higher throughput like
the eliezer or surveys essays and
definitely the NGS lab preparation there
you need a lot of deck space to work
with all the different kit methods so we
have a lot of accessories available for
our systems and over the 15 years of it
emotional we really added a lot of
things to it and we have about eight
different puppeting tools single or
multi channel and with that we can cover
a broad range of volume we can go from
0.2 microliters up to one milliliter so
this is really a broad range which you
can use for various applications we have
a gripper device to handle app wear in
the system and a lot of different
directs camera adapters and various
others accessories that can manage to
implement all the various applications
on the IMP emotion system and of course
we also have a good set of consumables
so tips and reservoirs to use in
addition we also offer all the needed
support services like maintainence IQ o
q-- services for implementation okay
that should it be with a short
introduction to our product portfolio
with that I would like to summarize
today's webinar um so I hope you could
see that there are many applications and
routine tasks that are really reasonable
to automate and all of these
applications consist of workflows and
that can be defined in certain building
blocks easy to transfer to deep emotion
and I hope that Tim could show you that
with the way the programming is done
that is very intuitive to do and that a
set up of certain applications is also
really quick to do on on deep emotion
system so in addition to will be easy
and intuitive programming of the system
I hope that I also could show you some
other good advantages of automation
which makes it reasonable to switch to
an automated system device ok with that
I would thank you for attention and
Tim and we are now available for any
questions that you might have we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started we have an ample
number of questions already coming in
from our audience members gentlemen you
demonstrated that there reservoir rack
can hold multiple types of tubes vials
and other things can the tube rocks hold
different ml tube sizes yeah a very good
question though
yes our X can hold tubes of different
sizes so 0.5 ml tubes 1.5 ml tubes and 2
ml tubes and it is also possible to have
a mix of different tube sizes within one
rec for one application we call this mix
rec left where and in the lab where
selection which you can do in the
software you can find a selection of
predefined mix racks which you can use
for your application providing 0.5 1.5
and to milliliter Eppendorf bars and a
certain combination thank you and can
the pipettes be calibrated and if so
does open door offer this service yes of
course any parting device need
calibration after a certain time the
tools have an electronic chip in it so
they will recognize
any parting action and they will notify
the user after about two hundred
thousand parking actions there will
message pop up and ask for calibration
so and then it depends on the country
but in all countries we definitely
provide calibration service and in most
of the countries we even provide on-site
calibration service in some smaller
countries you have to send in the
paddling towards for calibration in one
of our offices
yeah but definitely calibration of
targeting devices is very important
thank you and what is the lowest volume
you can pipe it um the the lowest volume
we can type it as 0.2 microliters so
this effectively allows also to
downscale certain applications for
example PCR or qPCR setups just as a
reminder the highest volume we can
pipette within one transfer step is one
millimeter and we cover this range from
0.2 to 1000 micro litre with four
different tool sizes great thank you we
have an amazing audience today and a
comprehensive class set of questions
coming in here's one how do users know
which tips to choose so the this is done
one part by the software where the user
has to define if they want to use a
filter top tip or a non sensitive so on
that is done in the setup of the
properties of the sample transfer or
reagent transfer and then it depends on
the selected volume and the pending tool
and the instrument by the software will
then pick the right tip from the tip
boxes provided on the deck so that is
not something that need to be programmed
by by the user the system
and the software will do this activity
automatically and it will take the next
available tip so if it's an 8-channel
tool it will take the next role if it's
an single-channel tool it will remember
where the next tip available in the box
and by that it will use up the complete
box of tips and of course can go to the
next box of available tips if required
so that's done by by means of software
the only thing is to do or define if a
filter tip is to be used for this
pattering action or an onset a tube
thank you gentlemen and our next
question is what does this look like if
you are transferring in nine samples
yeah I assume that you are referring to
a certain slide which I will quickly
open so that one over here so it's you
can easily transfer also nine samples so
this would then mean that the sample
from this sauce vessel goes into a four
five and six and the system would also
recognize this automatically if you tell
it before that you want to use twenty
four samples for example in total and
you're also not bound to do your
triplicates in this horizontal
orientation you could also simply do it
vertically so it's your choice and
believe me the pattern recognition works
really well so the pattern you are
choosing will very very very lightly be
recognized by the system Thank You our
next audience question comes in two
parts the first part is is it possible
to perform different dilutions using
different factors and then can you
dilute vertically not only horizontally
across the whole place the
very good question also something which
you see in a number of applications yes
you can dilute using different factors
but not within one dilute command so
that would mean that if you want to
dilute with different factors you have
to use several dilute commands depending
on the diluting sector but for one
eyelid command you can go for every
factor that you want basically for the
second part of the question
you can also dilute vertically you can
also read horizontally over a plate
vertically and horizontally I'm sorry
yeah so both directions is fine however
you want to dilute it will work great
thank you we have time for one more
question from our audience members how
do you help a customer know when it is
appropriate for them to switch from
typist to EP motion so um that depends
on the on the application the customer
is doing and usually it is worse
speaking with our sales representatives
about the application and depositing
that is down the routine tasks in the
lab and as we demonstrated there a lot
of routine tasks where puppeting is
involved which can definitely be
transferred to an automated system and
we are happy to talk with the customer
if the application is is feasible and
what would be the required
instrumentation to use it for and then
in details discussion about the
application our salespeople our
specialists will help to set up the
right configuration and with that we can
even then have on demonstration of the
software or even place and demo system
inside
of the lab of the customer is really
required but we have many routine
applications what we can have good
argumentation and convince the customer
to provide the budget for and one of our
motion systems so the deputy the next
step is to talk with our product
specialists in in sales thank you so
much and gentlemen thank you for your
presentation today and we know that you
will be answering all further questions
via email do you have any closing
remarks you'd like to provide the
audience before we close today yeah
thank you for the attendance it was
amazing to see that so many people were
interested in today's webinar and we
hope you enjoyed the performance of our
talk and also thank you Susie and
crystal for the good moderation of this
event and with that thank you everybody
and yeah let's close the session thank
you so much gentlemen and I'd also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 2018 you
will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thanks for joining us
we hope to see you again soon
goodbye goodbye